il
oh
pétillante
allo forcier f1 soleil samedi
on joue et intelligent
et
alors je suis qu'à l'aune g
j'ai 28 ans et j'habite à bras panon et
je suis auteur poète
en ce moment les en résidence dans cette
salle c'est pas vraiment une des plus
petites salles de l'île
mais c'est très belle salle très chaude
très intime avec en discutant cjd et de
ceux notés domaine donnery de frange
noire les i way c'est la fenps on était
un peu trop redondant et j'ai publié mon
premier livre en 2010 sega mon dieu
galets et après ce premier livre là je
sentais que j'avais envie de plus
partager mes idées
c'est le projet l'a fait noir donc on a
un projet au fait tourner on est sur
deux aspects le premier aspect c'est la
scénographie et la deuxième le deuxième
aspect c'est tout l'accompagnement
scénique vocale et technique aussi
toluna peau qui est son père
oui je sais ce que je veux mais je sais
pas trop comment le faire et donc pas
d'où l'utilité d'une équipe quoi que là
ils ont aussi deux plans en tête
en fait ça dépend de ton imaginé passer
bain de des maquettes au réel pour il a
fallu revoir les dimensions même
dispositif pour l'humain leur nature
fait l'inversé
d'où l'utilité d'une d'une résidence
aussi en clair chacun vient avec ses
compétences et renforcer le projet du
coup nous on a aussi comme on est
accueilli par les cadres départementaux
on a aussi un soutien en termes de
communication est également et de
production surtout pouvait encore du
moment mais après on connaît les
difficiles ne sont pas des nao tout de
suite tout ce que vous va il ya une
tension parce que je pense que c'est la
pression qui monte aussi parce qu'on est
à quelques on a une semaine du spectacle
bon là c'est encore le chantier non mais
normale 3 de nora trois sur scène nora
trois sociétés sorte de monde arabe
c'est pas une pièce de théâtre c'est pas
un concert c'est pas super spectacle de
danse
du coup on est un peu partout mais on
n'est nulle part
donc ce qui est important pour nous
c'est de trouver des codes en fait sur
scène et donc l'arbre 50
oh
salut ça va oui ça va et où sa rencontre
en dehors sauf des sports le bisou le
goût de la lecture déjà d'abord ça a été
transmis par ma mère elle m'offrait des
livres j'avais envie de les lire et
abandonné à force du lien qui vive on a
envie d'écrire un peu plus déjà au à
l'école primaire
quand il fallait récité des poèmes
j'adorais ça au jour d'aujourd'hui il
est difficile d'être un peu ce qu'on est
quoi on est dans une démarche
spirituelle et qu'elle a voulu
intellectualiser la démarche spirituelle
et que apparemment ça a donné ça nous
dans notre famille ma grand mère
justement il faisait les services
cabaret et
elle avait des moments aussi magique
aussi blanc gens que je gagnais je t
avais les pièces des billets tout ça
plutôt les pièces parce qu'une croix
lumineuse terrasse maintenant avec mon
regard d'adulte et ils avaient tous les
enfants tes copains tout pouvoir
attraper les pièces et to imagine aussi
que bien sûr elle cérémonie du coup
qu'ont les enfants ou imagine que les
ancêtres mais là il vient et donc du
cros du coup mais crois que mon
imaginaire et l'a développée quand même
assez tôt je dis moi j'accroche vous
sort ils savent à la crèche ou tonnes de
thé veut continuer monde vélo dehors
mais non ils savent aller copains
oui
j'ai toutes ses racines qu'elle est
comme ça en fait c'est à dire que nana
déjà une graine que les plantes est en
train de développer
c'est à dire que c'est toute une culture
il faut un peu de différences ne pas
toujours être pareil vivant bas et oui
oui moi lila lila gay et je te lis tu
lis comme la firme a dit cet instrument
là en fait cessé un sac à dos mais je
découvre vers l'instrument que je joue
maintenant
lors d'un voyage ça me semblait assez
simple à jouer en fait déjà c'est une
percussion donc ça me semblait assez
assez facile à
à jouer et en plus ce qui était
intéressant aussi c'était que à la
réunion ça n'existait pas et donc
personne pouvait me critiquer
aïe
mc au mieux son quart acoquiné
sont calés en sol est à croquer
a confié
c'est pas du talent travailler avec mon
nom c'est vraiment naturel
il sent que la nasa rhonelle depuis
toujours en fait est bon il joue juste
avec un mbira et
avec salif espace plein d'émotions
lénine à la côte est avec sa voix c'est
la difficulté là pour le monde pour moi
jamais travail avec une scénographie je
dis bien au ballon travail allanon oui
c'est ça tu vois qu'à les voilà tous les
moments où tu sens que tu as pas bien un
mouvement refait le sens contraire mon
profil elle est très très bien se
profile avec ses fils à qui seront
suspendus
là tu as tout un mouvement comme sa
suite on a abordé des choses vraiment de
l'ordre de l'intimé de notre famille ça
ne la grandit coup ça a été important
pour nous mêmes de leurs du spirituel
marion de la place du maloya dans notre
vie des racines ou trouve que je dit il
faut que ce soit une personne qui compte
dans le paysage artistique réunionnais
je trouve ce qu'elle dégage c'est
magnifique il faut que les gens le
public la connaissent c'est pas si
courant que ça on à vous dire en parle
d'évolution c'est sûr que lille évolue
beaucoup depuis 30 ans mais il ya
quelque chose qui voilà qui est évident
pour nous c'est que maintenant plein
pour la couleur de peau n'importe qui
peut prendre cette parole en chef buste
là ça peut y aller c'est ces nobles
maloya noble femme catherine debout
c'est ça voilà la femme relève bien la
tête comme ça c'est vraiment voilà mon
mieux debout deschamps voit juste
quand on chante et puis c'est fini mais
voilà ce qu'est ce qui est difficile
c'est de coordonner un petit peu tout ça
à la famille le projet professionnel et
coordonnée même
le
le projet de résidence
m
bon c'est ça ouais ça va bien et toi ça
va j'ai eu peur en fait le spectacle en
hommage à nos ancêtres
mais dans cette classe tapis sans qu'ils
aient fait travailler des faits feux
d'artifice éclatent votre énergie
ans
m
c'est les gens et ressentent ça l'amour
qu'on a mis dans notre travail qu'on a
mis aussi entre nous je dis tu me fais
elles vivent quelque chose là elle vit
comme ça en plus c'est une artiste
talentueuse qui a beaucoup de choses
aussi à dire que son message soit
entendu pouvoir tenir son public encore
longtemps pour pouvoir y vont fort ce
casse la baraque
telle est la fin chose non seulement
assumer surtout qu'elle est une
ouverture exceptionnelle et que voilà le
monde entier la réclame et c'est pour
moi les gens euros sans ça c'est bon
c'est gagné